[Musique]
parce que bon ben tous les ans les faits
on a fait mais tous les ans dans
d'autres
[Musique]
oui fais des bonnes movies de l'eau à
l'infini tu dégaines
[Musique]
et après
voilà quoi
mais pense les vrais comme c'est pas que
parmi un petit plus en moins voilà mais
sans Ali pas comment expliquer par
contre il ressent ça dans vos derniers
titres comment va se passer quand on l'a
écrit les dernières chansons par exemple
c'est l'inspiration même on dirait le la
Huet des clics mais pense qu'il m'avait
un chêne de mon pied bien de mon cou et
que nos affaires cassées
parce que bon ben comme nous connaît
déjà l'école à apprendre la nouvelle ta
bêtise qui concerne même pas nous et
Benga comme moi là nous si bonne
haut-parleur
pense voilà mon utilise mon musique à ma
poule en tout cas n'importe où
[Musique]